it's the seventh grandchild that
President Biden refuses to face and that
makes him a total disgrace the White
House coldly shutting down questions
about hundreds estranged four-year-old
daughter
there was a story in the New York Times
over the weekend about Hunter Biden's
daughter in Arkansas how does the
president acknowledge this little girl
as his granddaughter I don't have
anything to share from here mmm cold
that damning New York Times piece
reveals how Biden AIDS are told to
flatly ignore Hunter's daughter a quote
in strategy meetings in recent years
aides have been told that the bidens
have six and not seven grandchildren
according to two people familiar with
the discussions
I wonder which lying dog face pony
soldier they got that from
best part of it all I have six
grandchildren and I'm crazy about them I
speak to them every single day not a
joke matter of fact they just got
finished going through the calls and
guess what they're crazy about me
because I pay so much attention to them
that is heartbreaking when you hear that
contrast you know Katie I've noticed a
pattern among the bidens you know that's
not my laptop that's not my gun that's
not my cocaine that's not my child is it
any wonder that half the country says
that's not my president
I guess not
in your face
um
first okay so the New York Times printed
this so now all of a sudden it's a story
like it's been a story for four years
and now I'm glad they're being asked
about it directly at the White House but
this is something that people have known
about that has been reported on and it
was called a conspiracy theory and now
all of a sudden after many court cases
and being served multiple times they're
having to address it by saying we're not
going to talk about the seventh
grandchild and it's not just Joe Biden
who refuses to acknowledge it Jill Biden
I would say is just as bad because when
she decorates the White House for
Christmas she only hangs six stockings
which is just absolutely abhorrent and
it's just not true when he says he has
six grandchildren he doesn't he has
seven of them and he ran on being Mr
empathy Mr family clearly that's not
true but the problem with this for them
is that it brings the consequences of
Hunter's bad behavior into a reality and
that's what they don't like they think
they can bury the laptop because the
media did it for them they think they
cannot talk about hunter's Behavior
you're from the White House Podium
because he's a private citizen but when
it comes to having an actual human child
there it's very clear that Hunter's
Behavior has caught up to him and when
you don't want your child to have your
last name it's pretty disgusting I can
imagine I mean I I don't know this but I
believe Joe Biden claims that he's
pro-life right
even though he's yes he's like halves
he's like half pregnant yeah yeah yeah
yeah well my point being that I'm sure
that you know
he would be happier if that child didn't
exist
certainly acts that way
I don't think yeah
I don't think so I think that this is a
moment where the president really could
have told his son enough's enough like
I'm happy to deal with all this other
stuff I'll take it about what the
business ceilings the addiction the go
the videos whatever we can handle this
but this is Humanity right this is the
face of it and I found the article to be
very difficult to read frankly and the
fact that she knows who she is made it
so much worse you know because there are
there are a lot of people floating
around who don't know who their family
is right they don't know their dad is or
they were put up they were left
somewhere and they ended up with
wonderful people who took care of them
but this is someone who is proud of the
fact that her grandfather is the
president of the United States and
doesn't get acknowledged and frankly the
American people would care zero percent
about this right like they would just
say oh he has seven grandkids yeah
Hunter slept with this woman and I was
trying to figure out the throughout the
story like what's the problem with this
family right is there some the Trump
supporters big you know big deal if
you're willing to accept someone who was
an addict like that and made such
terrible choices like it's so bad that
they vote for the other guy and I don't
think it's something that will change
votes necessarily but it is just an
ugliness that doesn't need to be there
it does feel judged in a way like a
class thing I mean the fact that you
know oh she's the uh the daughter's
mother is a you know let's just say a
dancer
right
assistant the mother in this case is a
college graduate she played basketball I
think was it at Arizona State University
I mean this is a woman it was a very
bright woman and she apparently worked
for Hunter's company uh and you know she
we're not talking about someone you know
who is embarrassment and and the the
look at it this way her family can say
you know what we love America you know
we don't want to be associated with the
bidens they're corrupt they collect
money from other countries the economy
is a mess but they don't they're
desperate to have this child named after
the bidens what father what family would
be so insistent that this child not have
the Biden last name to me that's cruel
and when this little girl grows up and
she starts to understand what she may
even be beginning to understand now
because she knows her grandfather is a
president she knows who her father is
you know this is going she's going to
have a lot of issues emotional issues
that the bidens who were allegedly a
family centered on their family lives
around their grandchildren according to
the New York Times they're not what they
want you to believe and and by the way
they not only had six stockings uh for
the grandchildren they had a Christmas
stocking for the dog I mean these are
these are really classless people and
America understands America would accept
this they wouldn't just accept that a
lot of families have this problem where
there's an extra marital Affair and a
child is born and out of wedlock child
two single people have a child they
don't know about it until five months
later there's a lot of this going on
it's not an embarrassment
Charlie I think the biggest lie we were
told about Biden was that he was gonna
he was an empathizer but I always I get
the feeling that that was about this
deep that he really could feel his feel
your pain but he won't do anything about
it and this is perfect good advice I
mean perfect example of it yeah uh his
entire campaign in 2020 was about out
being empathetic being decent he was
going to restore normalcy to Washington
um and obviously has failed on every
every front of that
um and uh but it's what's sort of
interesting is that he's sort of been
bobbing around Washington for so long
most people in Washington already kind
of knew this side of him they knew that
he was a uh sort of a liar they knew
that he made things up he would just
talk about anything uh he would say
anything that helped him at any given
moment
um and uh when he talked about his
family people in Washington also kind of
knew that he was uh less of a family man
and more just willing to exploit his
family when it served to benefit him if
you remember in 2016 uh when after
basically after President Obama decided
to support Hillary Clinton which
foreclosed uh Biden's ability to run in
2016. he blamed his decision to not run
on his the death of his son right and
then of course you know he has exploited
his bio the biography of his uh first
wife who died 50 years ago with his
daughter uh and in that accident both of
his sons were were injured he's of
course uh taken that story and and
twisted it around to talk about how the
driver of the truck was somehow drunk
which is completely false uh the
accident was caused by uh by when she
pulled out in front of a truck driver
who was just driving but that that sort
of callous heartless willingness to
exploit even your family and then turn
around and and who who's embarrassing
here the family or the bidens as you
point out
um and but but to them if they if he
sees it as a political Advantage he has
no problem doing that and I didn't just
say so I don't I don't think that the
American public or at large thinks that
about Joe Biden or the bidens and we can
get into the Washington
well it matters who elects him right and
recover
fine but this really is a story about a
father that will not put limits on their
son right this is what Hunter Biden said
I don't want this child around and so
his dad said that's fine but he didn't
but he didn't have to put limits on him
because they had the body name that's
the gross part about it it's not just
the relationship with the dad and the
son it's how they basically use their
power to make sure they're impervious to
the law when you think about all the
people going through health because of
January 6th this guy's got the sweetest
sweetheart deal if they find the Coke
does he still have that deal I mean if
they find out if they find out that
Coke's his does he still have that deal
it's a good question right if anybody
else would get blown up for it yeah
January six people did a bad thing this
is not like they didn't I'm saying it
this guy's got a a you know a mountain
this high of bad things and he'll keep
doing it because there's no
disincentives you can just keep going
I'm jealous I wanna Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now